I'm fun he's a little too fun to be
honest oh man so early come on hit the
snooze button I mean you had fun last
night maybe too much fun you don't need
to hit that snooze button you could
always sleep when you're dead
just think of all the fun things that
you can do today there's breakfast and
there's work and there's lunch this is
going great you're getting things done
staying focused you know what I think
you need more tabs open I mean you could
open up a tab of that video of that
singing monkey oh and then one for that
mansion and then one for that article
about bananas this is actually relaxing
you know what is relaxing being on
vacation I mean the Sun the surf the
likes influencer status you become
[Music]
hey you can give me ten more I mean you
could keep struggling through that or
you could take a photo of the Matt post
it with the hashtag fit fam hi there how
did you day I see that you like dogs I
think we have a lot in common
seriously how about sorry I'm lost
can I get the directions to your heart
okay or what about you must be my phone
charger because without you there is a
lot to do here
but you know what we could do instead
skydive blindfolded he's a little too
fun to be honest you're a highly
functional organized and methodical
beast and I bet that you could tear
through this whole pile right now if you
try you know what I can do both
[Music]
that reminder to do the dishes tomorrow
[Music]